trois catastrophes naturelles qui vont
se produire mais on ne sait pas quand un
le big one c'est un séisme qui va
survenait en californie causés par la
faille de san andrés il pourrait être le
plus fort jamais recensés aux états unis
d'une magnitude estimée à 9 2 les
tempêtes ou éruption solaire elles se
produisent à la surface du soleil et
envoie dans l'atmosphère de la matière
ionisée à des millions de kilomètres
si elles atteignent la terre ou sa
proche banlieue ces tempêtes peuvent
perturber les satellites les champs
magnétiques et créer un black-out
électrique 3 le vésuve ce volcan italien
notamment connu pour avoir enseveli la
ville de pau pays sous les cendres en
l'an 79 c'est un volcan plisnier en
produisant des nuées ardentes autrement
dit des nuages de gaz et de poussières
incandescente est considéré comme l'un
des plus dangereux au monde en raison de
sa tendance explosive mais surtout parce
que des milliers de gens vivent à ses
pieds